من اول ما بدات اولى حلقات مسلسل سره باتع
او سر الباتع اللي هو من تاليف واخراج
خالد يوسف بمشاركه اكثر من 60 فنان وفنانه
والجدل على المسلسل المتوقف بدايه من
الديكور الملابس مرورا بملامح بعض
الشخصيات وانتهاء بالموسيقى التصويريه
اللي بتشهد تصعيد وتطور جديد فمن اول حلقه
الناس علقت على الموسيقى وقال له انه نفس
موسيقى فيلم الريس عمر حرب ولكن طلع
المؤلف الموسيقي راجح داوود واللي هو مؤلف
موسيقى الفيلم واسمه كمان على تتر سره
الباتع كمؤلف للموسيقى التصويريه طلع
الموسيقى وقال انه ما في تشابه في
الموسيقى وانه مو نفسها وما بتتشابه معاها
ابدا وكنا نحنا استضفنا المخرج خالد يوسف
في احدى حلقاتنا من كم يوم وسالناه عن
الانتقادات اللي الناس بيقولوها ولكنه
فاجئنا برد مختلف عن كلام راجح داود خلينا
نسمع اشكال
ترجل على موضوع الموسيقى صاروا يقولوا انه
خالد يوسف بيستعمل مقطوعات موسيقيه سبق
واستعملها في افلامه لاي درجه هذا الكلام
صحيح
مثل ما شفتوا المخرج خالد يوسف قال كلام
عكس كلام راجح داود فقال انه صحيح
الموسيقى استخدمها من فيلم قديم وانه هو
حر الجديد في الموضوع اليوم انه المؤلف
راجح داوود مسكت وفجاه الناس امس ببيان
حول القصه فقال انه هو تعاقد على تاليف
الموسيقى التصويريه للمسلسل وافق المخرج
على كل التعديلات والشكل النهائي للموسيقى
وسلمها في الوقت المحدد ولكنه تفاجا في
الحلقه الاولى ان الموسيقى اللي مستخدمه
كان الفها لعمل سابق وهو فيلم الريس عمر
حرب لنفس المخرج وقال انه اعترض على اللي
صار بس المخرج قال له انه ما في مشكله
لانه الموسيقى من تاليفه والفيلم لخالد
كمان وتابع انه هو ما اقتنع بالحديث ولكنه
سكت علشان ما ياثر كلامه على الجمهور اللي
بيتابع العمل وانه تجاهل كل الاتهامات
اللي سمعها عنه ولكن بعدين لاحظ في موسيقى
بتستخدم في المسلسل مو من تاليفه ولا يعرف
مين الفها وهنا نزل بيان عشان يوضح اللي
بصير وقال انه هو تعود انه يحترم جمهوره
وما بيقبل انه تنسب له موسيقى هو مالفها
ولا حتى يقتبس من مؤلف اخر واعتبر اللي
صار جريمه وقال انه اللي صار ما بيجوز تحت
اي ظرف ولا اي تبرير صراحه
ابدا يعني والناس صارت تتساءل لو في خلاف
او ايش اللي صاير بالضبط خالد يوسف ما ترك
الناس تتسائل كثير وطلع بفيديو على
حساباته ورد فيه على كلام الموسيقى خلينا
نسمع اشكال
كل سنه وانتم طيبين انا طالع النهارده ارد
على استاذي الموسيقار الكبير راجح داوود
في البيان اللي طلعه
استاذ راجح بيني وبينه مواد ده وعلاقه
طيبه جدا واشتغلنا مع بعض قبل كده من اكتر
من 15 سنه في فيلم الريس عمر حرب وكانت
تجربه جيده جدا
وذكرياتها سعيده جدا بالنسبه لي وبالنسبه
له
البيان اللي هو طلعهم ما ازعجنيش خالص ولا
ضايقني لان هو حقه حقه ان هو ينبه الجمهور
ان في مزيكا موجوده على المسلسل مش من
تاليفه حتى لا يعتقد احد ان المزيكا دي
تنسب ليه ووصف انه لو حد فهم ان المزيكا
دي منسوبه له وهي مش بتاعته ان ده جريمه
اللي انا عملته بالجريمه لان ده حقي
المطلق في ان انا احط المزيكا اللي انا
احسها ملائمه للمشهد وملائمه للمود المشهد
بين وجهه نظري
الاستاذ راجح داوود لازم نبقى يعني عشان
جمهور العريض يبقى عارف برده حتى لا
يتهمني بان انا اساتي ليه لان حشر الله ان
انا اسير الاستاذ راج
اداني المزيكا التصويريه بتاعه المسلسل
بعد طبعا مديته الحلقات قبلها باكتر من
شهرين كل حلقه تباعا كانت بتجهز كان بتروح
له
اداني المزيكا قبل قبل رمضان بحاجه بسيطه
بايام قليله يعني فجيت احط المزيكا على
المشاهد لقيتها غير كافيه
استخدمتها كامله يعني مش ان انا شيلت
مزيكا راجح داوود وحطيت مزيكه حد تاني لا
انا استخدمت كل مزيكا راجع داود لكن في
مشاهد كتير لما لقيتلهاش مايلهمها في
المزيكا اللي هو بعتها لي فاضطريت ان انا
استخدم حاجات من افلام القديمه وطبعا
مبدعينها
استاذنتهم قبل ما استخدم ده ووافقوا جدا
ورحبوا بكل يعني بكل سرور الاستاذ راجح لو
هو شايف ان انا استخدمت مزيكا غير مزيجته
وكان عندي وكان في مزيكا ملائمه للمشاهد
انا بدعوه لتجربه كده عشان
يمكن اطلع انا غلطان انه ياخد اي مشهد انا
حطيت عليه تامه موسيقيه مش بتاعته
ويشوف ايه المزيكا اللي هو عملها ملائمه
لهذا المشهد ويضعها على هذا المشهد
والحلقات موجوده عنده وينشر الاثنين ينشر
اللي انا حطيته وينشر اللي هو اللي هو كان
عاملها لهذا المشهد واللي هو شايفها
ملائمه ليه واشوف انا وانتم اذا كنت انا
كنت غلطان في ان انا احط مزيكه اخرى ولا
هو كان عنده حق